ich habe mich aufgeregt immer noch muss
ich sagen es sieht so ein bisschen eine
bereits brinkhaus den vorsitzenden der
cdu fraktion im deutschen bundestag
brinkhaus hatte kürzlich beim parteitag
will die union da sehen wir ihnen eine
rede gehalten und sich aufgeregt über
die grundsatzvereinbarung der ampel und
ich zitiere gesagt das ist die stramm
links agenda liebe seit jahrzehnten in
deutschland gesehen kamen sowie geben es
ist wahlkampf auch in der union vier
männer alle aus nordrhein westfalen
bauen fraktionsvorsitzende werden dessen
job da hat man ein großes auto oder hat
man große dort hat man viele mitarbeiter
gehen geht es natürlich um politik
umgestaltung und damit eine rede von der
cdu nachwuchs netz um ja zum casting
auftritt betreibt trinkaus in der rolle
des scharfrichters versteht den wirklich
in diesem sanierungs papier der april
keine steuererhöhungen kann antasten der
schuldenbremse ab 2020 keine ökologische
klima diktatur im übrigen auch keine
abschaffung der privaten
krankenversicherung und aus der nato
treten wir auch nicht dazu natürlich 12
euro mindestlohn bürgergeld und so
weiter und das soll nun wirklich die
trams der links agenda seit jahrzehnten
in deutschland sein getragen von
jemandem wie christian lindner fdp chef
schauen wir uns doch mal selbst an was
die cdu in den letzten jahren so oft den
weg gebracht hat die abschaffung der
wehrpflicht hier für alle in einer
freien abstimmung des hick hack um den
atomausstieg mit dem endgültigen
atomausstieg unter angela merkel und
auch man muss es sagen die
flüchtlingspolitik war auch nicht das
was man früher als seine konservative
lehre betrachtet die ware linke agenda
der letzten jahre wurde ausgeführt von
der cdu unter angela merkel dass angela
merkel als person als respekt die
persönlichkeit des schaffen hat und
gebunden hat das ist nun weg und diese
wählerinnen und wähler sind jetzt auch
weg und die cdu ist entkernt und hat
viel zu spät darauf reagieren das ist
ein gott ich kann sie nicht sparen lena
warum armin laschet in jüngsten umfragen
noch acht prozent zustimmung hat da
stimmt die cdu braucht eine politik der
erneuerung aber nicht mitreden die im
bierzelt stadt im bundestag gehalten
werden geht er wird aber ein denkfehler
gibt es jetzt schon bei dem was ich
gesagt habe der
deal für alle wo die er vorbereitet
vorbereitet durch das gleiche das gesetz
das war die rot grüne agenda aber es ist
ja in einer offenen abstimmung
mehrheitlich getragen worden auch von
abgeordneten aus der cdu insofern als
dass es ein fehler war wegen fehlender
abstimmung im bundestag hat die union
das ja mehrheitlich abgelehnt dass ich
hier für weiten teilen dafür gestimmt
deswegen ist die nicht in der mehrheit
der abstimmung offen gehalten worden
damit viele mitglieder der cdu sich
dafür merkel hat dagegen gestimmt war
wir müssen einmal einmal herrn boss noch
zu wort
die
zuschauer haben es nicht gesehen wer hat
hier ganz stark gelitten ihr gesprochen
hast wähler also die zivi eine linke
partei also zunächst mal abschaffung der
wehrpflicht ist nicht ganz richtig
aussetzung sie war auch aus
verfassungsrechtlichen gründen nicht
mehr zu halten und trotzdem ist ihre
beschreibung richtig war abgeschafft ist
die wehrpflicht nicht
für alle richtig die base agg
allgemeines gleichbehandlungsgesetz aber
es ist auch richtig dass eine ganze
reihe von abgeordneten der union
zugestimmt haben angela merkel und
wolfgang bosbach allerdings nicht aber
sie hat durch ihr interview bei der
brigitte den weg für diese abstimmung
frei gemacht dafür haben und sie hat
auch in harvard war es glaube ich dafür
feiern lassen und nicht widersprochen
dass sie diese bahnbrechende
sozialreformen auf dem weg zu mehr geht
es um einen anderen punkt ich kann das
ja menschlich verstehen es haben alle
das büßerhemd angezogen jetzt wollte er
mal den kampfanzug anziehen ralph
brinkhaus aber ich teile seine thesen
nicht die strengsten links agenda ich
glaube wir tun uns auch als union selber
keinen gefallen wenn wir nicht
differenzierter argumentieren und dass
ich das mal cdu man sagen muss ich bin
ja vor dass die fdp dabei ist bei den
verhandlungen in der ampel und ich bin
überrascht wie viel sie doch
durchgesetzt hat nicht aber ich weiß
auch das kleingedruckte kommt noch
entscheidend wird die
koalitionsvereinbarung seien
entscheidend werden die nächsten vier
jahre sein aber das was jetzt vorliegt
würde ich auch jedenfalls in teilen
nicht unterschreiben aber nur stramme
links agenda werden jedenfalls jusos und
die grünen nicht teilen dass das stramme
links agenda ist und hat so auch nicht
vor er meint es aber schon
gesellschaftspolitisch nicht also das
ist glaube ich das entscheidende was
bringt aussagen wollte und wenn wenn ich
da lese dass sie jetzt beschließen
wollen dass man mit 14 sein geschlecht
festlegen und auch wechseln kann dann
ist es ja durchaus etwas neues was man
auch ganz links verordnet sondern über
es gibt keine ein modernes einwanderung
ist ja was heißt soll es so ja das wird
ja noch relativ und seien deshalb viele
doch gesagt dass ich unter anderem auch
christian lindner das ist heiß dass wir
natürlich arbeitskräfte brauchen das
sehen wir überall in nordrhein westfalen
und in jedem bundesland das wir aber
tatsächlich uns öffnen sollen für die
besten der besten so dass wir hier
wirklich qualifiziertes fachpersonal
haben und diejenigen hier helfen unsere
jobs zu besetzen die wir besitzen
inzwischen ruft gerne die besten der
besten können jetzt schon kommen nach
geltender rechtslage jederzeit und die
guten die haben nicht nur die wahl
zwischen heimatland und deutschland die
haben die wahl zwischen heimatland
deutschland und mehreren dutzend anderen
länder ist wo sie hingeht dann müssen
wir auch mal über eine andere frage
spricht warum wandern immer mehr auf
high potentials aus deutschland aus mehr
als 100.000 pro jahr weil sie in anderen
ländern so richtig gute leute und eine
bessere perspektive hat dann müssen wir
auch attraktiv sein als standort für
hoch qualifizierte arbeitnehmer absolut
so wird es auf mich mit dieser ampel
koalition auf den weg gebracht werden
aber es gibt viele andere sachen die
auch geplante stärkere stop der
diskriminierung der sind wir wieder beim
thema in diesem fall eine gute sache und
mehr gleichberechtigung also was das ist
ja eine agenda das ist nicht die linke
ist dieses meinetwegen jetzt auch common
ground also die es wird ja von allen
geteilt gut aber sprechen wir mal über
das thema migration da hat herr
brinkhaus heute nachgelegt und hat
wirklich davor gewarnt und es ging
natürlich um die situation an der
deutsch polnischen grenze und er meinte
er warnt davor dass die ampel einen weg
geht der auch mit europa überhaupt nicht
kompatibel ist dass man jetzt plötzlich
so weit öffnet also im prinzip noch
weiter als frau merkel die cdu geöffnet
hat dass deutschland da einen ganz
eigenen weg einschlägt glauben sie ja
also
wie sehen sie die migrations vielleicht
wäre es noch ruhig wenn man werde jetzt
mal die fachpolitiker herankommen würden
bis zur stunde ersetzt das wort asyl an
trag an der grenze alle einreise
voraussetzungen die es ansonsten gibt
passt schlecht fällt weg wer einen
asylantrag stellt wieso brauchst du
nicht asylantrag reicht für die einreise
nach deutschland nicht als mann
anerkannt wird reicherzer rein kommt und
wer ohne gesichert die identität und
nationalität kommt hat eine hohe
wahrscheinlichkeit niemals abgeschoben
werden zu können weil wir die identität
und nationalität die ware nachweisen
müssen dann von genen die jahre und dann
kommt der wunsch jetzt ist doch so lange
her jetzt lassen ihm auch einen
verfestigten aufenthaltstitel geben wir
haben damals noch unter rot grün das
zuwanderungsrecht verändert das ist aber
die regulären migration wir sprechen
hier im ersten teil über die reguläre
animation aber woran hat das dienstende
nicht geschafft seit fünf jahren man hat
doch das war politisch so gewollt es war
politisch so gewollt dass wir niemanden
an der grenze zurückweisen der einen
asylantrag stellt obwohl wir von neuen
demokratien umgeben sind sie kommen aus
anderen staaten aber sie kommen über
gefestigte demokratien trotzdem
politisch gewollt weisen wir niemanden
an der grenze zurück also geht es um die
frage wer soll zukünftig kommen dürfen
wir nach jetziger rechtslage nicht
kommen darf und ausmustern in der
koalitions vorhanden jährigen jetzt bin
ich neugierig wer hat es denn politisch
gewollt in der in der zeit als die union
regiert hat jetzt zunächst einmal die
bundeskanzlerin die entscheidung der
flüchtlinge die damals allein garish im
osten doch das war reines
verwaltungshandeln es ging um das war
reines verwaltungshandeln es ging um die
schlichte rechtsfrage ob das europäische
recht was ein selbsteintrittsrecht
vorsieht das deutsche recht was ein
anderes recht wenn ich rechts soll
zurückweisung hat überlagert und da hat
die bundesregierung reines
verwaltungshandeln ist neben deutschen
bundestag beschlossen entschieden dass
wir von dem selbsteintrittsrecht
gebrauch machen und niemanden an der
grenze zurück war das ist ja
undemokratisch ich dachte das
entscheidet der bundestag
ich wäre ja auch etwas ganz anderes in
erholen als beispiel wird jetzt
tatsächlich
der innere die innere konflikt oder der
konflikt ausgetragen auf der auf dem
rücken von brüssel und auch von anderen
westlichen europäischen ländern indem
man sagt was brüssel nicht schafft eben
diese flüchtlinge aufzuhalten das werden
wir tun wir wollen eine mauer bauen
nichts das ist ja ein bekanntes vorbild
ich habe gestern die schon erwähnten zu
weißrussland und hier entsprechend uns
davon abschotten und das ist noch
schöner kann sich die ampel doch genau
darauf ausruhen man kann also eine nette
schöne liberale einwanderungspolitik und
koalitionsvertrag vereinbaren sondern
erdogan uns die ein flüchtlinge vom leib
hält und die polin jetzt handeln dann
funktioniert das du
[Musik]